[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la piraterie aussi
ancien que le commerce de mer ce fléau
des routes maritimes continue à faire
des ravages dans plusieurs régions du
monde
presque 200 attaques en 2020 et ce ne
sont que des chiffres officiels alors à
quoi ressemble ce fléau
aujourd'hui vols de bateaux de
marchandise kidnapping abordage attaques
armées
en 2020 les pirates même près de 200
attaques
le bureau maritime international
s'inquiète particulièrement de l'ampleur
de la menace dans le golfe de guinée
devenu depuis peu l'épicentre de la
piraterie mondiale pour faire face à ce
défi de nombreux pays concernés joignent
leurs efforts et maintiennent une
coopération en matière de lutte contre
les pirates du 21e siècle
les etats-unis et l'union européenne
renforce eux aussi leur présence
militaire sur les routes maritimes
stratégiques et mènent des opérations
conjointes
pourtant le résultat de tous ces efforts
est plutôt mitigé car les causes qui
alimente la piraterie ne sont pas
vaincues office riz de gouvernance
activités des groupes armés pauvreté
chômage
en 2020 la pandémie du comique 19
aggrave encore plus la situation
économique mondiale poussant bon nombre
de personnes vers des activités
illicites en mer
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur l'ampleur actuelle de la
piraterie dans le monde c'est le blitz
selon le bureau international maritime
195 actes de piraterie sont enregistrés
en 2020 c'est plus qu'en 2019 mais d'une
façon plus générale c'est une baisse
notable par rapport au début du siècle
au 469 attaques avaient été enregistrées
par an un nombre record sur tous les
incidents de cette année 20 attaques qui
ont échoué et trois navires ont été
détournés dans le même temps on se bat
au ont essuyé des tirs
les pirates sont par ailleurs passés à
l'abordage et sont montés à bord cent
soixante et une fois la zone la plus
touchée par la piraterie et le golfe de
guinée qui est à l'origine de la plupart
des cas d'enlèvements dans le monde
s'en suivent le détroit de singapour et
l'indonésie
plusieurs incidents ont lieu au large
des côtes de l'amérique du sud dans
l'océan indien et en mer des caraïbes
dans le golfe du mexique et celui du
bengale le new constate une hausse
alarmant de la piraterie maritime dans
le monde le nombre le plus élevé des cas
est détectée dans le golfe de guinée et
plus précisément très décote nigérienne
le gouvernement de ce pays n'arrive pas
à juguler la menace au niveau régional
la coopération patine aussi dans l'asie
du sud est
autres zones touchées par la piraterie
la situation est différente dans cette
région ces états se sont rassemblés en
une force multilatéral la récap censé
lutter contre le fléau
son effet est reste pourtant limité la
pandémie du comité 19 ne fait qu'empirer
les choses
l'économie régionale souffre et cet état
des choses n'arrange pas du tout les
poids lourds géopolitique qui met en
place plusieurs initiatives visant à
sécuriser les principales routes
commerciales en mer c'est le cas
notamment des états unis et de lieux qui
renforcent leur présence dans les zones
maritimes et mènent régulièrement des
opérations anti piraterie
pourquoi malgré une forte implication de
la communauté internationale la
piraterie cotutelle à prospérer
à quoi ressemble les pirates des mers
aujourd'hui
quelles sont leurs modes d'action pour
répondre à ces questions nous rejoignons
jean-paul pancracio spécialiste de droit
international public
professeur émérite à l'université de
poitiers et chercheur associé au centre
thucydide de l'université paris ii
panthéon assas monsieur pancracio
bonjour bonjour les régions les plus
frappées par la piraterie aujourd'hui
sont le golfe de guinée l'asie du sud
est
pensez vous que les causes de ce fléau
soient les mêmes pour chaque région
oui absolument alors les modes
opératoires des pirates
si on veut sont différents selon la
région
mais là la cause essentielle tient en
trois éléments si vous voulez d'abord
une relative pauvreté sur les côtes
donc sur les populations côtières
ensuite sur la côte
un état qui ne contrôle pas qui est
relativement faible voire défaillants
comme c'était le cas
carrey band de la somalie dans les
années 2008 et suivantes et l'essentiel
c'est une route maritime très importante
qui parce qu'ils passent au large avec
toutes les richesses du monde vous savez
que et 95 % des marchandises qui
s'échangent dans le monde à travers le
globe passe par la voie maritime
et c'est le cas en particulier il ya des
zones sensibles comme le détroit de
malacca qui et voilà vous les navires
sont parfois attaquer mais il ya là il
ya toujours ces trois éléments pauvreté
sur la côte voire des pêcheurs qui dans
dans les zones de pêche ont été dévastés
par la pêche industrielle et qui n'ont
plus que cette ressource pour vivre un
état qui ne contrôle pas tout ce qui se
fait sur la côte est
voilà au large une route maritime très
importante
vous avez dit que résister à ces
attaques coûte cher maintenant je
voudrais parler des équipages en général
les bateaux des pirates eux sont mal
équipés
mais pourquoi les équipages des
vaisseaux ont-ils habituellement du mal
à résister aux bandits ou les choses
changent
aujourd'hui d'abord les équipages
si vous voulez des navires entre
consigne de ne pas répliquer par eux
mêmes soit ils ont une équipe de gardes
armés embarqués
c'est ce qu'on appelle les équipes de
protection embarquée qui sont d'aider
d'anciens militaires en général voir des
militaires d'activé qui sont diligentées
par les états sur les navires qui
battent leurs pavillons mais s'il n'y a
pas ces équipes de protection embarquées
on interdit aux équipages d'avoir des
armes à bord et est et pourquoi on leur
interdit
pourquoi on leur interdit de se défendre
alors parce que on a peur que ça
entraîne une élévation du niveau de
violence de la part des pirates
ensuite tout simplement parce que la
plupart des pays interdisent que les
navires privé les navires marchands et
des armes à bord et viennent avec des
armes dans leurs ports dans leurs eaux
territoriales
alors c'est très simple et du coup
messieurs compte en banque ratio du coût
vient la question est évidente à mon
avis est ce que vous pensez que le droit
international maritime devraient se
réadapter à ce fléau de la piraterie le
ce qui concerne la piraterie est assez
bien normes et dans le droit
international aujourd'hui on peut
poursuivre les pirates ont peu les
intercepter real etc
mais on ne peut pas chaque état et à la
maîtrise du droit qui s'applique sur les
navires qui bat son pavillon si vous
voulez et donc voilà il pleut il pleut
très aisément interdire aux marins de
ses navires de répliquer à des attaques
pirates
il ya les équipes de protection
embarquées qui maintenant sont autorisés
sur les navires
on peut y recourir si la piraterie se
développe merci beaucoup monsieur
pancracio nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur le thème de la
piraterie merci encore dans le golfe de
guinée les pirates se sentent de plus en
plus à l'aise le 23 janvier il attaque
le navire le mozart exploité par une
compagnie turque à 320 km des côtes du
nigeria
l'équipage s'enferment dans le château
un espace sécurisé mais en vain les
amarres mais enfoncent la porte et
pénètre dedans un matelot et tué 15
membres d'équipage sont kidnappés trois
semaines plus tard ils seront finalement
libérés ils sont accueillis à l'aéroport
international d'istanbul par le chef de
la diplomatie turque
les circonstances et les conditions de
leur libération restent pourtant flou
quelques semaines après cet incident le
bureau maritime international publié un
communiqué dans lequel ils s'alarment de
l'essor de la piraterie dans la région
les incidents illicites dans le golfe de
guinée présente actuellement une menace
grave et immédiate pour la sûreté et la
sécurité des équipages et des navires
opérant dans la région
le bmi ne manque pas de souligner le
golfe de guinée représente actuellement
la zone de navigation la plus dangereuse
du monde
la région compte 95 % de l'ensemble des
enlèvements en mer et les incidents ils
sont particulièrement graves plus de 80%
des pirates possède des armes à feu
comment expliquer une telle ampleur de
la piraterie dans la région
la réponse est plutôt dans la situation
socio-économique des pays du golfe de
guinée
selon le crisis group le problème
principal vient du déficit de
gouvernance qui à des degrés divers
caractérise l'ensemble des pays de la
région
celui-ci se greffe à l'extrême pauvreté
à une corruption endémique à l'activité
des rébellions communautaire et enfin au
chômage environ 40% de la population
active et plus de 60% des jeunes n'ont
pas de travail dans les pays du golfe de
guinée
une longue ligne côtière et la porosité
des frontières sont deux autres facteurs
dont les pirates profitent pleinement
pour eux le golfe de guinée est une
véritable aubaine
des centaines de bateaux y circulent
chaque jour une partie du navire se
limite à un cabotage locale en
sillonnant le long des côtes
d'autres transportent des marchandises
vers les pays régionaux en provenance
d'europe et plusieurs autres états
cependant le plus gros trafic vient de
l'exploitation pétrolière
le nigeria étant le premier producteur
d'afrique c'est au large de ses côtes
qu'ont lieu la plupart des attaques en
2020 35 incidents ont été enregistrés
près du nigeria et cela malgré de
nombreuses mesures prises par le
gouvernement nigérien pour contrer la
menace pirates au niveau régional la
lutte anti piraterie patine aussi une
situation qui force certains pays à
chercher de l'aide à l'étranger
le 11 janvier le ministre des affaires
étrangères de guinée équatoriale
rencontre le sous secrétaire américain à
la défense
anthony jean tata l'entretien est centré
principalement autour du problème de la
piraterie
le ministre demande le soutien américain
formation du personnel mise en place
d'un mécanisme d' échanges
d'informations fourniture d'équipements
et de matériels en effet washington est
déjà fortement impliqué dans cette
région qu'il considère comme stratégique
la marine américaine et déploie
régulièrement des forces navales mn d
exercice d'envergure
l'un des derniers en date est celui de
la formation au ban game express
organisée en 2010 9 34 pays 2500
personnes 95 navires et 12 aéronefs
l'ampleur des manoeuvres militaires et
sans précédent l'objectif de l'exercice
est de renforcer la sécurité maritime
contre les pirates et d'améliorer la
surveillance de la ligne côtière à par
washington à un autre poids lourd
géopolitique s'ancre de plus en plus
dans le golfe de guinée
c'est l'union européenne le 25 janvier
bruxelles annonce la mise en place de
son concept de présence maritime
coordonnées au large de la côte ouest
africaine
l'objectif est de renforcer la
coordination entre les marines
nationales largement présente dans la
région celle de la france de l'italie de
l'espagne
elles pourront désormais s'échanger des
informations opérationnelles via le
réseau de surveillance maritime
européenne
marc sûr alors comment se poursuit la
lutte contre la piraterie dans d'autres
régions du monde pourquoi ce phénomène
ne fait-il que prendre de l'ampleur ces
dernières années comment la piraterie at
elle évolué au cours des dernières
décennies
la réponse après la pause au moins une
vingtaine de cas de piraterie sont
enregistrés depuis le début de l'année
le chiffre est certes alarmant mais il
n'a rien à voir à la situation d'il ya
dix ans lorsque la piraterie
contemporaine avait connu son apogée
l'histoire de la piraterie moderne prend
sa source dans les années 80 le nombre
d' attaques de pirates explose en
afrique de l'ouest et particulièrement
au large du nigeria raison le boom des
exportations pétrolières dans le golfe
de guinée en 1983 à l'organisation
maritime internationale adopte une
résolution appelant les gouvernements
concernés à prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour prévenir et réprimer
les actes de piraterie un appel qui
reste largement sur le papier les
pirates continuent à sévir dans le golfe
de guinée
et dès le début des années 90 il gagne
du terrain dans les détroits de malacca
et de singapour où passent les
pétroliers du moyen-orient les vraquiers
d'afrique et les cargos des états unis
le nombre d'attaqués qui passe de trois
en 1989 à 309 en 1999 une hausse sans
précédent qui pousse les pays de la
région à s'unir face aux défis communs
dès l'année 2000 le japon met en place
avec l'inde et la malaisie
des exercices navals anti pirates quatre
ans plus tard
l'indonésie la malaisie et singapour
lance des patrouilles coordonnées
maritimes et aériennes la coopération
régionale porte un coup sévère à la
piraterie
mais celle-ci ne disparaît
c'est à cette même période que la
piraterie explose près des côtes
somalienne plongée dans une interminable
guerre civile depuis des années 90 ce
pays connaît une crise humanitaire
d'envergure pauvreté famine faiblesse du
centre fédéral
mogadiscio des conditions qui créé un
terreau fertile pour l'activité de
piraterie à celle ci s'ajoute aussi la
situation géographique avantageuse de la
somalie qui se trouve à proximité du
golfe d'aden par lequel transite environ
20000 navires chaque année les pirates
ils sont largement des pêcheurs locaux
qui cherchent à gagner leur vie
au début des années 2010 c'est la zone
la plus dangereuse du monde en 2011 237
incidents et sont signalés et 216
membres d'équipage sont pris en otage
sous prétexte de lutte anti piraterie
l'otan déploie ses forces navales au
large de la somalie
la chine la russie l'inde et le japon et
y envoient aussi leurs navires de guerre
la situation se stabilise peu à peu
l'épicentre de la piraterie mondiale
devient l'asie du sud-est et dès l'année
2018 c'est le golfe de guinée
rien qu'en un an les pirates il même 82
attaque un chiffre inouï pour cette
région à la croisée des routes maritimes
premier producteur régional du pétrole
et pays le plus frappé par l'activité
pirates
le nigeria renforce ses forces navales
et adopte une loi anti piraterie
mais ces mesures s'avèrent peu efficace
la coopération régionale ne donne pas
non plus de résultat
en 2020 la piraterie connaît une hausse
alarmante dans le golfe de guinée et
aussi au niveau global
en fait qui sont ces pirates qui
menacent la stabilité des échanges
commerciaux dans des régions si
différentes
tout d'abord ce sont des voyous des
mères qui se tourne vers la piraterie à
cause de la pauvreté dans certaines
zones comme la somalie ou le venezuela
les pirates sont d'anciens pêcheurs
poussé par la surpêche à attaquer des
navires
il y a aussi les gangs financé par des
mafias et d'autres groupes criminels
en effet entre 2005 et 2012 les pirates
de la corne de l'afrique reçoivent plus
de 330 millions de dollars de rançon
l'argent est largement utilisée au
profit des groupes armés il existe aussi
un autre type de pirates
ap les terroristes maritime ils
attaquent des bateaux pour des raisons
idéologiques ou politiques
quelles que soient leurs motifs les
pirates d'aujourd'hui utilisent
largement les nouvelles technologies et
l'équipement bateaux rapides système gps
dispositif de vision nocturne téléphonie
par satellite
tout cela complexifie davantage la lutte
anti piraterie en 2020 le trafic
maritime mondial s'est contracté de 4,1
pour cent selon l'onu et pourtant la
piraterie elle est en hausse à défaut
d'atténuer l'engagement des pirates ces
des brigands dans leurs activités
illicites
la crise sanitaire aura contribué à son
maintien et même à son essor
la pandémie et la piraterie sont deux
phénomènes étroitement liés l'année
dernière le pib mondial a perdu 4,3 pour
cent
la crise a poussé environ 120 millions
de personnes dans l'extrême pauvreté
par le passé ce sont ce genre de crise
et provoquer aussi un essor de pirate
fin des années 90 la crise financière
asiatique provoquent une brusque hausse
d' attaques en mer autour de l'asie la
crise économique globale de 2008 elle a
été suivie par 3 années d'insécurité en
mer cependant les efforts internationaux
dans la zone la plus à risque au large
de la somalie permettent tout de même de
minimiser l'impact de la piraterie
aujourd'hui dès 2008 le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu autorise le
déploiement des forces militaires
étrangères dans le golfe d'aden pour
protéger ce corridor stratégique
la même année l'union européenne entame
son opération navale anti piraterie
atalante a qui continue jusqu'à ce jour
le temps a contribué aussi à cette lutte
avec ses opérations aux jeunes schild
qui a duré huit ans et allied protector
en 2009
enfin les forces maritimes combinées ont
joué un rôle important aussi
ce groupe de 33 pays et mise sur pied
par washington en 2002 pour assurer la
sécurité autour du moyen orient et des
2009 le groupe se focalise sur
piraterie et multiplient les patrouilles
et les exercices multinationaux le
résultat de tous ces efforts est
frappant depuis 2010 8 au large de la
somalie aucun incident n'est enregistrée
par le bureau international maritime
entre temps une autre zone cruciale du
trafic maritime est dans le viseur des
pirates
c'est l'asie en 2020 c'est la deuxième
zone la plus dangereuse au monde pour
les navires après le golfe de guinée
surtout dans le détroit de singapour
incontournable sur la voie depuis
l'europe ou l'afrique vers l'est
le nombre d'attaqués pirates et à
doubler en 2020 par rapport à 2010 9,2
même aux philippines
particularité de la région la plupart
des attaques visent des petits navires
et ne sont pas violentes souvent les
pirates ne sont même pas armées
en fait en 2020 74 % des cas de
piraterie en asie sont classés en
catégorie 4 pas d'armes chez les
attaquants et pas de blessé dans
l'équipage les attaques ciblent surtout
les bateaux mouillés près des côtes ou
dans les ports mais pas en haute mer
pourquoi c'est que la plupart des
nouveaux pirates asiatiques sont
d'anciens petit commerçant la pandémie
les prive de sources de revenus
traditionnels comme le tourisme ou la
pêche ainsi un indonésie le chômage
progresse de 50%
autre facteur contribuant à la hausse
régionale d'attac la résurgence du
terrorisme comme par exemple autour des
philippines justement ces dernières
années le pays est tourmenté par le
groupe terroriste abou sayyaf qui
multiplie des attentats et enlèvements
sur le sol et des attaques pirates en
mer la hausse de 2020 arrive en dépit
des efforts substantiels de la région
pour contrer la piraterie
depuis 2006 les pays asiatiques sont
unis par le récap l'accord de
coopération régionale contre la
piraterie et les vols à main armée à
l'encontre des navires en asie celui ci
permet de coordonner l'action des pays
membres et fournit les statistiques pour
la région les opérations spécifiques des
pays riverains sont centrés sur les
zones les plus sensibles
le détroit de malacca et les meurtres et
des philippines enfin la région
accueille régulièrement des exercices
anti pirates
nationaux ainsi début février 45 pays
prennent part aux manoeuvres
ammann organisé par le pakistan tous les
deux ans depuis 2007
hormis les pays régionaux les états unis
contribuent aussi au combat contre les
pirates en asie depuis 2016
il entraîne équipe et assiste les
marines locales dans le cadre d'un
programme régional
washington est engagé au même titre en
amérique latine la coopération anti
pirate international est quasi
inexistante et pourtant c'est un foyer
émergent de la piraterie mondial en 2020
15% des actes de piratage ont été commis
en amérique latine et dans les caraïbes
en cause l'insécurité sur le continent
la criminalité comme au mexique
l'effondrement économique comme au
venezuela où les défaillances de l'état
comme en colombie
les pirates sont souvent armés les
attaques violentes en plus des navires
commerciaux le brigandage affectent
largement la navigation de plaisance
quoique inquiétant le nombre d'attaqués
près de l'amérique latine restent peu
élevés par rapport aux autres points
chauds
or parfois les chiffres de la piraterie
peuvent s'avérer flou plusieurs médias
décrivent la hausse constante des
attaques sur l'infrastructure pétrolière
maritime au mexique depuis 2016 même si
ces données ne sont pas confirmés elle
suggère une possible insuffisances du
signalement des incidents dans le golfe
du mexique
comment peut-on combattre le problème si
on en connaît même pas l'étendue pour
mieux comprendre la piraterie mondiale
la france apporte sa réponse en 2016
elle lance son propre centre de la
sécurité maritime à vocation mondiale
appelée le mica center il recense et
analyse des attaques en mer et publie
des rapports précis sur la situation
dans le monde
à titre de comparaison en 2020 le centre
recense deux fois plus de piratage dans
le monde que le bureau international
maritime
le mic cassone terre aide aussi à gérer
prévenir des attaques en mer qu en temps
réel en mai 2010 9 grâce au centre
français le transporteur néerlandais et
évite l'assaut armé près de la guinée
équatoriale
selon l'onu environ 80% de tout le
commerce mondial passe par la mer du
coup la sécurité en mer contribue à la
croissance économique mondiale
le monde est il prêt à affronter une
nouvelle vague de piraterie quelle
stratégie peut-on appliquer à part la
réponse militaire pour mieux comprendre
aussi les pirates se maintiendront au
21ème siècle
nous revenons vers jean paul en cruciaux
spécialiste du droit international
public professeur émérite à l'université
de poitiers et chercheur associé au
centre thucydide de l'université paris
ii panthéon assas monsieur pancracio
l'amérique latine est elle un hub
émergent de la piraterie aujourd'hui
faut-il s'attendre à une hausse des cas
là bas dans un avenir immédiat
écoutez je ne crois pas sincèrement je
ne crois pas parce que comme je dis
l'heure il faut qu'il y ait à terre si
vous voulez des états qui sont trop
faibles pour contrôler ce qui se passe
sur leurs côtes
et ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas quand
même du venezuela ni de la colombie qui
sont les vraiment les deux grands états
concernés par cette route maritime qui
traverse les petites antilles pour aller
en bouquet le canal de panama
donc les autres états sous voulait le
brésil l'argentine le chili ce sont des
états vraiment suffisamment opérationnel
puissant pour contrôler leur côté sur le
dans leurs eaux territoriales ou au
large la mer on ne relève pas de cas de
piraterie
peut-être un à la sortie de la deûle
amazon mais c'est effectivement très là
donc il ya deux étapes qui pourraient
être concernées c'est le venezuela s'est
essentiellement là que ceux au large de
ces eaux qui lie à des attaques
à l'heure actuelle parce que il est sûr
de la route vraiment du canal de panama
d'accor ticket quel est l'avenir de la
piraterie monsieur pancracio sera t-elle
complètement éradiquée à un jour si oui
comment où va-t-elle peut-être changé de
visage à l'église de changer de visage
je le vois pas être éradiquée parce que
d'abord et des zones peuvent toujours se
diversifier dans voit qu'elles ont
évolué il ya quelques années il n'y
avait pas du tout de piraterie dans dans
la mer des caraïbes
par exemple il y avait une très faible
piraterie dans le golfe de guinée elle
est venue après celle de la somalie
il y avait déjà de la piraterie dans le
détroit de malacca certes il y en avait
très peu au large du bangladesh par
exemple dans le golfe du bengale
donc on a vu que les zones se sont
diversifiées mais tant qu'il y aura des
richesses incroyables qui passeront sous
le nez en mer pas loin au large des
populations côtières pauvres on risque
d'avoir d'être confronté toujours à de
la piraterie
par contre ce que je sous entendais tout
à l'heure où ils risquent d'évoluer dans
son mode opérationnel parce que si on
met à l'eau comme les recherches tentent
à avancer en ce sens des navires
autonome
là on aura affaire à des pirates akers
qui pourront électroniquement s'emparer
d'un navire le dérouter et le raven est
gentiment de façon automatique en ayant
un contrôle sur ces les voilà sur c'est
incroyable il ya eu déjà des cas comme
comme celui que vous venez de décrire
non pas encore parce que on en est
vraiment
aux essais sur les navires autonome sans
équipage mais c'est quelque chose qui
peut et qui peut inquiéter parce que les
on sait bien que les hackers s'en sont
lassants très performant et il n'y a
jamais de systèmes suffisamment cryptée
pour pour leur échapper ou enfin ça
c'est difficile donc au risque d'avoir
ce type dans les décennies qui viennent
c'est pas demain mais ça peut être 2000
quand on peut avoir une piraterie qu'il
devienne vraiment une piraterie
s'invente alors là ce seront
certainement pas les mêmes pirates
ce sont des des groupes criminels
organisés
voilà voir éventuellement des états qui
s'attaqueront qui referont de cette
manière une sorte de lire de course
comme elle existait au temps des
corsaires cela incroyable machine
incroyable impressionnant merci beaucoup
monsieur pancracio jean-paul pancracio
spécialiste du droit international
public professeur émérite à l'université
de poitiers et chercheur associé au
centre thucydide de l'université paris 2
panthéon assas était là aujourd'hui avec
nous pour apporter son analyse dans
cette émission cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]